[Music]
what are you watching on TV these days I
think I watch a lot of the same shows
that most people watch you know I do
like this one reality show it's not even
really a reality show I call it a
reality show it's I call it the hot
chick Trials hot chick triumph that's
correct
it's these pretty women that are on
trial for murder and they never seem to
get convicted
you know like Casey Anthony that Amanda
Knox student in Italy right pretty but
no conviction and here's my theory why
as long as there's a guy on the jury
he's not gonna convict them because he's
hoping one day he will run into them on
the street and say hey remember that
murder trial you're up for I was the one
that say no not you not her she couldn't
have done it you think that they're just
hoping that they can hit on her one day
and use that leverage that's a theory
that's a theory and and I kind of get a
- cuz I was watching that Casey Anthony
trial for like four days in a row and I
think I myself she's kind of cute I hope
she doesn't go to jail but then on the
fifth day she came out she had her hair
be hundred years I notice that her ears
looked a little big and I thought well
maybe she is guilty
our justice system at work now this is
exciting news we have kids at the same
school the school for the very gifted
and ball rehab it's called rehab yeah
okay
oh and and you're gonna be the MC of the
school benefit to raise money to this a
couple years ago I was the emcee a
couple years ago yeah yeah it's it's
it's really a lot of pressure I mean I'm
pretty more work into this than if I was
doing like the White House
Correspondents Dinner right because you
know what you know when I first got into
comedy I did a performing a cruise ship
it was a four-day cruise and I bombed
the first day and I had to avoid those
people for the next four days until we
got back to Miami so where did you where
do you hang out you just stayed I stayed
on my little stateroom yeah under the
bed
yeah anyway if I bomb at this thing
this is gonna be like a 12-year cruise
yeah because that's the thing had that
occurred to me when I had to emcee it is
that you you were gonna be in this
school until they go to college probably
you're gonna be there for a long time so
if you my biggest fear is that some of
the people from the cruise ship will be
there yeah
I've got some good material lined up ah
pal I gotta I gotta work on that
yeah you know when is it I forgot when
this thing is it's in a couple days I'm
not going to that
you don't go to those things no I I will
go there's you know the parent
everything this guy is a dedicated
father this is just a hobby for him but
the father thing I mean he's at every
pancake breakfast there's one a year
right no there's two a year to year and
it is a different era though you know
these days we're all supposed to be
involved with our kids you know this
Indian they want you at school all the
time and in my day in my day my father
never showed up at school when I was a
kid he was off doing his job
but these days it's like can you come by
tomorrow for the pancake go yeah hey goo
goo
I haven't really been to one of the
pancake goo Goo's no you gotta check
that out
yeah but I'm excited about it that's all
I got for you my practice all I wanted
to get out of you that was worth a long
pause and maybe a sip you know this is
actually the first time I've had coffee
in my cup I noticed you had coffee in
there not water yeah I'll tell you why I
do that I like that because that's why
it's an idiot
I love you but you're an idiot is this
so this show how long is this show how
long is this show more than an hour we
established up top that it's an hour an
hour that you wish you could have back
is in honor of daylight savings time is
Alex Trebek really here that was Alex
Trebek yeah is it Alec or Alex what are
you doing right now
things to do I'm sorry what do you mean
you didn't know like there are other
hair let's see you're like you did not
care no I'm just a loose nice boat I
hope that seemed like I didn't care
I thought maybe somebody cancelled here
we've got lots of gas